harrison
you can't everyone close to you dies
that's why we're here
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about the ending of dexter new
blood but real quick this video is
brought to you by squarespace use their
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business at
squarespace so how should dexter new
blood end the original series that aired
between 2006 and 2013 for eight seasons
is remembered fondly for a lot of things
but having a critically acclaimed or
even satisfying finale isn't one of them
and that's not just my opinion the
original showrunner clyde phillips who
left after season 4 but has returned for
new blood and dexter himself michael c
hall have expressed that part of the
reason they wanted to come back and do
the revival was because the original
ending was disappointing but in this
video we're not talking about how it
could have ended differently in the past
or what's wrong with the original ending
what i want to look at here is how this
limited event series should end what
would be the most satisfying what would
make the most sense and then at the gut
level how do you want it to end so i'll
be talking about what i think the most
likely ending is out of the different
options what makes the most sense to me
and as far as spoilers i'm not going to
get into too many of the details i am
making this after episode 6 of new blood
came out but i'll be talking about the
ending generally rather than getting
really deep into the specifics of what
happened in this season and with that
out of the way let's get into it
so i'll say up front what i would like
to see is a conclusive ending for the
character clyde phillips has said in
interviews that this is going to be a
big ending that's going to break the
internet which i mean that is his job is
to hype things up i still try to temper
my expectations about endings but he
says that he believes the finale is the
best thing he's ever written and that
it's going to be surprising inevitable
and it's going to blow up the internet
that last part would seem to make a
happy ending where dexter gets the life
he always wanted somewhat unlikely so i
won't be spending too much time talking
about that one and i guess there's a
couple of things that we have to throw
out there as i mentioned he left the
show after season four and was critical
about the ending of season eight when it
came out he actually shared what his
idea that he never pitched would have
been if he would have finished the
series saying that his personal ending
for the show was that he was going to be
executed for his crimes he's laying on
the table and outside the window or all
the people he's killed so basically the
last scene would have been dexter facing
his demise and all the characters that
had been introduced in the show that he
had killed or he had been close to
they'd all be there looking on i think
that probably would have been less
divisive than what did happen but this
idea has been out there for eight years
and most people have heard it even if
they're not die hard fans so it seems
pretty unlikely that they would go ahead
and make that the ending and that he
would still be publicly talking about
how that was his idea back then and just
real quick in case you forgot about what
happened at the end of the original run
dexter fakes his own death after he took
his sister deb off life support ending
her life and she was on it because of a
decision he made he decided to abandon
his son and leave him with hannah who
was also a killer who he had grown close
to because he was able to be himself
around her she knew he was a serial
killer and accepted him how he was he
chose a self-imposed exile because i
guess he figured that everyone close to
him eventually died so they were better
off if he wasn't around considering the
response to that i think it's safe to
say they shouldn't go in that direction
again so how could it end then well if
it's to be a conclusion then he could
get caught he's already killed a couple
of people in iron lake and that would be
enough to put him away for a long time
but even though he'd been hiding out and
laying low before that there are
possibilities for him being exposed as
the bay harbor butcher as well there
might be relief in that for dexter he
wouldn't have to pretend to be something
that he's not anymore and it would clear
doks's name as far as his relationship
to his son it might make sense of why he
did some of the things he did the
abandonment and the not being able to
connect but i'm not sure that a
relationship between them exist after
the fact and their inability to make
that work has been a big part of what
new blood is about although angela and
her newfound connection to miami or
molly and her familiarity with the cases
there and her suspicion about dokes not
really being the killer those two are
both in a position where they could
figure out his secrets if it came down
to it i think angela would turn him in i
don't see a big exciting ending that
involves her deciding to stay with him
and not exposed the truth if she figured
it out the only way it might feel twisty
or crazy though would be if he happened
to confess to harrison in confidence
trying to help him out with his own
situation only for him to betray that
and turn him in i guess if you really
like the character and you don't want
him to die then this is probably the
preferred ending but i think it's the
least satisfying out of all the ones
that make sense and i'll get into the
other options after this quick mention
of today's sponsor squarespace recently
i wanted to put together a website and i
found squarespace to be really user
friendly it was simple to jump right in
and start to create a website or you
could put together an online store with
marketing tools and analytics built in
for what i was looking to do the video
blocks were great just paste the url and
upload a custom thumbnail and i
appreciated that all the templates have
built-in mobile websites just make it
once and it looks great across all
devices while you're working you can
toggle the views back and forth and get
the design just how you like it check
out squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
pete peppers to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain i do
think the ending should involve harrison
and if we're talking about what might be
shocking then you have to consider him
putting dexter in a situation where he
might decide to kill his own son i don't
think the show has gotten to a place
where that would feel right like it
would sound awful if it was just that
hey he fits the code so dexter decides
to kill him but if they were trying to
go in that direction then they could do
some things with the character and maybe
they could set it up it's always tricky
with dexter though because in most
situations if someone had to kill
someone in their own family that would
be a huge deal you would know that that
character was suffering as a result that
really wouldn't be the case here would
it so possibly shocking but a lot of
work would be involved in making it
satisfying i think that also extends to
the idea of them working together
there's not much that seems like it
would be a satisfying ending in that in
the early videos i made about the show i
got a lot of comments predicting that
dexter would learn that harrison has a
dark passenger and teach him the code
and to that i always thought and then
what happens you don't make a limited
series and say you had an idea for an
ending that was both satisfying and
inevitable and then deliver that what
the dexter story needed all along was to
have him partner up with his son and
just keep on killing that's more of a
beginning and it might have people
talking about it on the internet but i
don't think that would be in the way
that they were hoping for so if it's not
a happy ending not a team up with his
son not him getting caught and ended
with a lethal injection then he has to
get killed right suicide doesn't seem
consistent with the character so someone
would have to take him out there's
potentially a long list of people who
would want to do that if they knew what
he did and where he was there's
definitely people in iron lake right now
that would like to do that but again if
you're thinking in terms of shocking
having his son do it would be the way to
go the fact that fans say this feels too
predictable is a testament to the logic
behind it plus no one else in the town
has emerged to be a fan favorite
character there would be no added
emotional weight to any of them doing it
but at the same time if harrison and
dexter do work out their stuff then
anyone could kill him and that weight
would be transferred to harrison who
would really be losing something at that
point i do think that him dying has the
most potential and i did sort of
knee-jerk reject the idea of harrison
doing it whenever they first announced
that he was going to be back which means
i'd be fine if kurt or some other big
bad that hasn't been revealed yet did it
now that harrison is becoming a more
complete character at this point if
dexter died i would feel bad for
harrison or they could create a
situation where dexter has to sacrifice
himself for his son that would probably
be nearly as emotionally charged as
harrison doing it and so i wouldn't be
surprised if they went that route and to
be clear i'd be all right with any of
the options that i mentioned if they
made it work i think the only thing that
would really bother me would be if they
revealed that harrison was an imposter
all along that just doesn't make sense
to me at all considering that most of
the season has been about him and dexter
bonding together or their inability to
do so i get that some people don't want
to see the character die but in my
opinion one of the main issues the
series always had which was bigger than
a change of show runners or a bad final
episode was that it was really good at
building these really tense and exciting
seasons and then it had to try to outdo
itself the next time all while making
sure that the main character never got
caught never really got found out and
never died at some point it has to come
to an end and death feels like an end
and what's funny about the way this show
works even if michael c hall's character
dies if they ever wanted to make a
different spin-off show he could always
come back in the same way that they
brought deb back for this season his
father was never alive in the timeline
of the show yet he was one of the main
recurring characters his brother came
back his sister came back and if the
next show was about harrison then it
would make perfect sense for dexter to
come back i saw a post the other day
that said the reason that molly is there
is to tell the real story of the bay
harbor butcher after dexter dies and
that doesn't sound bad you could have
him exposed you could have that get out
there and that might be a nice end note
that's starting to get away from the
subject of the video though so i think
that's a good place to leave it let's
pick up a conversation like that down in
the comments let me know what you think
about how it will end how you'd like it
to end and what you think makes the most
sense please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon